chess has what is called its own
vocabulary how many of you know the word
vocabulary what it means very good
vocabulary is all of the words that you
know chess has its own vocabulary just
like in cookies there's ginger cookies
bake cookies chocolate chip cookies my
favorite word's
so chess has its own vocabulary so for
me to spill what's in my mind into your
mind I use words I'll show you what I
mean but I also try to be very specific
I like to use a chess vocabulary one of
the one of the best vocabularies in
chess is what we call the algebraic
system and what this means algebraic
system I'm not even sure where the word
comes from it the algebraic system what
it also does it gives us a very very
specific address for every square so
this square we understand to be a 1
correct a 1 this square this is the a
file this square we understand to be a 2
a 3
guys are getting better very good very
good
so when we start to use algebraic we
start to be very specific if I move my
night
what square is that F 3 tonight g 1 f 3
so I just moved my Knight to f3 and what
squares does the knight attack the
knight controls 8 squares when I went
Knight G 1 to F 3 it now controls 8
squares let's go back to the starting
position wrong here I'm gonna call it
out just think about it for a moment how
many squares does the knight attack for
that's amazing is it true which squares
that's 4 right
yeah good that was three so we start to
understand that when we bring our pieces
off the back rank these are the back
ranks our pieces start to control more
squares okay this is a very very very
important aspect of chess the more
squares my pieces control the less
squares your pieces control the more
opportunities I'm going to have to make
good moves now we all know what this is
very good
so in chess we say that we re we say
that the chessboard is our battlefield
and we divide the battlefield into
certain sectors for example we say that
I have my space you have your space my
space we say that the chess board has 64
squares correct okay so we're going to
draw an imaginary line across the middle
of the board we can call this the
equator if we like it's an imaginary
line but we say that these 32 squares or
whites they belong to white these 32
squares they all belong to black but
then we divide the board into more
sectors okay we notice that the King is
on the e 1 square and the Queen is on
the D 1 square we draw a square ok we
draw a square of 16 squares and we say
from e1 to h1 to h4 to e4 back to e1 do
you all see the square
White's kingside 4 or 16 so you count
all of these squares 1 2 3 4 5 yeah
correct there's four squares there's
this is White's King site
this is blacks King site correct now
notice the queen is on d1 we're going to
draw a square from d1 to d4 to a4 2 A 1
2 d1 and we call this White's Queen side
correct okay now why is this important
imagine that you and I are in a
restaurant together and we don't have a
chess set but let's say we're having a
conversation where I said how did you do
and you said I won how did you win
I checked it checkmated my opponent on
the Queen side so even though I don't
even have the game score in my hand
you've already conveyed to me an idea
the next thing we say is that there is
what we call the center there are two
central files anybody could guess what
they are
yes young
correct these are the center files and
that makes a great deal of sense why
because they're in the center of the
board now
chess grandmasters refer to four squares
four squares and they're called the
sweet Center the sweet Center those are
the four squares that ultimately we we
try to control in the opening in the
middle game why because when we control
the sweet center do any of you play
tennis oh good are you good tennis
player I'm not so good but I like to
play tennis and I like it when I hit the
ball with the sweet center of my racket
I hit the ball directly with the
strongest part of my racket well that's
what the chess board is our battlefield
and we're trying to control the sweet
center so I'm going to do today
something very very different I'm going
to play a game of chess against the
entire class okay but what I'm going to
do is very special I'm going to tell you
why I'm making the moves I'm making
right you don't have to tell me your
secrets but I'll tell you mine okay so
first of all mm-hmm you're the class is
going to be white yeah I got to give you
guys a little edge right I'm gonna give
you a little edge and how many of you
would like to play this as your opening
move that's pretty good
how many of you would like to play this
one as your opening move that's pretty
good
how many of you have a different opening
move that you would like to play okay
the e4 and the e4 crowd one okay this is
a very good opening moves there are many
many good opening move this is one of
the most popular Bobby Fischer said e to
e for Best Buy test that was how he
described this move let's think about
this move for a moment and why is it so
good
first of all you control two squares
right what's where's are they yes young
lady precisely precisely see that's how
cool chess can be you can be very
specific d5 and f5
one of the other advantages of this
opening move that you've just made is
you've opened up the diagonal for your
bishop correct okay when and you've
opened up the diagonal for your queen
correct when you started the game
notice that the bishop and the Queen
cannot move with this opening move you
freed the bishop now I have my space you
have your space how many of my spaces
does it's a trick question by the way
how many of my spaces in my sector of
the board my space with this move how
many of my squares do you control what's
your answer what's your answer now for
those of you who said to you know the
young lady
sorry the young lady has already said
too but that's at least two because this
bishop controls how many of my squares
young man one does it control this
square oh I meant the bishop so how many
of my squares does that Bishop six of my
space of my space too so hold on we have
two plus two equals none of you got the
answer right and that's not even the
right answer correct it's five why is it
five young lady
age five
so with that opening move you control
five of my spaces now what I like to do
when I was young and I still do it today
is I like to build a fortress okay what
do I mean when I build a fortress first
of all we all know that checkmate ends
the game right so ah hey what the safest
King I can possibly have so I like to
build a fortress I'm going to play here
and I'll show you how I build a fortress
with this move how many squares of yours
do I control three you guys have eyes I
don't have I recognize that my bishop
controls to this bar no this bond
doesn't control any of your squares
my queen it's only two okay your turn
yes him then what would you like to do
how many of you would like to play Queen
to h5 raise your hand so you like to
play Queen H right you like that every
would you like to play Queen h5 okay you
do - excellent excellent
okay now I'm going to share with you
what the Queen on h5 does because
probably many of you know the idea of
bringing your bishop and then with your
bishop here and your queen here you're
going to have a direct attack but when I
was a beginner I love my queen oh it was
the cat's meow I did I when I lost my
queen I was so forlorn how many of you
know the word forlorn how about if I
said sad
yeah I was so sad when I lost my queen
okay so I'd like to develop my queen
early but this is actually a beginner's
mistake why because the Queen so
powerful whenever i attack your queen
you're gonna have to move her right
young man what would you like to say
attack your queen yeah that's true
that's true but I'm not even gonna give
you the chance to get to that area also
called f7 and young men correct see when
I attack your queen because it's so
powerful I'm usually going to attack it
with something less powerful so you're
gonna have to move your queen so I'm
going to bring my knight to f6 yes and
this is called do you know what this is
called in in chest no that's an attack
this is an attack against your queen but
it's also an pawn correct
it is a fork actually correct I am
attacking your food it's a double attack
a fork is a double attack but it's also
called gaining a tempo gaining a tempo
what do I mean by that when it's my turn
to move I'm on turn right I I make a
move it means I I used a tempo but when
I brought my night out I attached your
queen and I'm going to force you to move
the Queen the class what would you like
where would you like to move your queen
yes in there
come on Queen a5 that's the square young
man what b5 that's Jack how many of you
like to play Queen to b5 check excellent
no oh that's ok so we've got 2 candidate
moves ok do you know what the word
candidate means no well a candidate is
kind of like an option you have an
option but you have lots of options you
could move your knight you could move
your pawn but your queen is attacked so
one suggestion was to go check correct
that's what I'm going to do correct and
the other option was to play Bishop so
you could check me with your bishop or
your queen how many would like to check
me with their Bishop how many would like
to check me check me with the Queen whew
that's a that's a tough call let's try
it again
with the bishop that's a lot of hands
with the Queen less hands we're gonna
let you guys play Bishop correct it's a
bad move why that's right after after I
block the check your queen is still
going to be attacked now I'm gonna block
the check with my pawn because I'm very
clever
now I am attacking to pieces I'm
attacking your Bishop and I'm attacking
your queen yes well if you take my pawn
on c6 you win upon but then I recapture
your bishop and who got the better deal
we're negotiating yay
why okay
correct because a bishop is worth three
pawns okay
so so I I did a real nice trade I like
you people
you're my favorite people now your queen
is attacked where would you like to move
your queen would you like to bring it
here to put me in a pinned how many
would like to do that wow that's
exciting how many of you would like to
retreat with your queen very calm safe
another idea what's another good idea
now don't forget I'm also attacking your
queen and pawn yes young man okay
so you're suggesting that when you bring
your queen to this square this pawn
protects my knight if I move my pawn
you're gonna capture my knight right
well thank you for sharing that that
means I'm not going to move my pawn
don't want to lose my knight okay
another move you could which one is that
okay
Queen to f7 you mean to capture the pawn
with check could I take your queen
would you like to lose your queen okay
we're going to let you play this move
and under normal conditions
I would capture your pawn very happily
but I'm not going to do that what I'm
going to do is I'm going to show you
what I like to do which is to build a
fortress
I play the Move g7 g6 so what's the idea
does anybody have does anybody know what
the idea behind this move is yes young
man yes that's correct
I but what this move does it's it
prepares my fortress what I want to do
in the 16th century how many know what
the 16th century means in the 16th
century the best chess players in the
world were Italian they all came from
Italy and they created what they called
the fianchetto so when I put my bishop
on the long diagonal the long diagonal
that's called a fianchetto so I play g6
with the idea fianchetto in my bishop go
ahead your turn what would you like to
do would you like to develop your
Knights would you like to defend your
pawn would you like to take my pawn
know you like to pick my father that I
would picture Queen no okay okay so how
many would like to develop their night
that's a good how many of you would like
to push your pawn forward would you like
to do that okay how many of you would
like to develop this night yes okay
that's a solid majority we're gonna go
with the solid majority now after Knight
f3
I play Bishop g7 okay so I create my
fianchetto now how many of you would
like to castle that is a very very good
move now I'll just tell you a quick
story I had castling is very very good
because it brings your King into safety
correct yes I had a very good friend he
passed away I'm sad to say his name was
Edward gue felt and he was a chess
grandmaster from the old Soviet Union
and he was the trainer of the Soviet
women's Olympic team yes and he was very
nervous about his team how they were
going to perform because there was a
great deal of pressure for the women to
win the gold medals so he would come to
the games late and as he would enter the
playing hall he would look for a Soviet
person and ask them in Russian how are
women doing and usually the answer was
they're doing fine
and then he would ask the next question
have they all castled and if the answer
was no then he would say he'd shake his
head very sadly and say we have to train
harder
so castling is very good and that's what
I'm going to do I'm going to Castle okay
now let's compare for just a moment
let's compare for just a moment you've
Castle Dan I've Castle
but I've done what is called building a
fortress why in front of my King stands
the bishop nicely protecting
besides my king stands my rook nicely
protecting and besides that I have a
knight like a century a good guard and I
have a beautiful pawn shield in front of
my king compared you castled you're safe
your rook is next your knight is and all
your pawns are safe so you have a good
pawn shield I have a good Pancho the
young man made an interesting
observation though also by my fee and
shadowing if we take away my bishop for
a moment my King also has a square at
the moment at the moment you're
vulnerable to back rank checkmate
how many of you know what a back rank
checkmate is very good you guys should
be teaching this class what are you
doing okay now it's your turn and keep
in mind the opening has not gone very
well I'm sorry to say I'm a pond I have
I have a bishop for a pond your turn how
many of you would like to develop this
Knight raise your hands
how many of you would like to advance
your pawn so you could yes how many
would you like to make another move a
different one
what's a different move for you rookie
one is an excellent move you're
defending the pawn that I am attacking
you've already castled so you've already
brought your rook into play so it will
cost you a tempo you'll be moving the
same piece twice if you move your room
how many of you would like to move with
your knight again okay how many of you
like to move with your pawn okay
so if I make this move does that have
your support yes okay now in this moment
remember what I said about your queen
and how powerful it was if I attack your
queen
I'm developing my pong correct I'm
moving my pawn from its original
position so I'm developing my pawn but
I'm doing it with a gain of tempo
because I'm gonna force you to move your
queen okay so now your queen is attacked
if you don't move your queen that's for
me so where would you like to move your
queen think about it for just a moment
in the back
Jenna young man what would you where
would you like to move the green Queen
to so you would like to retreat your
Queen to this safe Square correct okay
okay okay so we so I think a lot of you
would like to move Queen to b3 that's a
good move right yes yes now let's say
mmm you guys have me under some worries
here a bit I'm a little bit concerned
what am I going to know okay I see that
your queen is attacking my palm
correct correct so I'm going to move my
knight so my knight protects the pawn
and attacks your queen yes young man
what would you like to do okay
exactly my Knights attacking your queen
you don't move your queen that's for me
yeah that's for me
so how many of you would like to move
the Queen to c3 face your hands very
good how many of you would like to take
my pawn yes but I would take your queen
so okay I see the move Queen c3 is
popular with my audience how you do
what's another move okay the gentleman
is making a very good point if you had
moved your Queen to c3 just think about
it for just a second just a second
remember when I fianchettoed my bishop
on the long diagonal do you remember
that it's still there now if I were to
move this knight the bishop would have
what is called a discovered attack
against your queen yeah you see this
bishop is actually in ambush is waiting
in ambush and I would capture your pawn
attacking your queen with my knight
attacking your queen with my bishop and
also notice that did I leave this knight
in capture why correct you remember when
I started the lecture and I said how
important words are in chess and how you
can be very very specific the young man
made a very very specific observation
it's a double attack a discovered
doubled attack that's correct
so imagine remember we were having a
meal together and you were telling me
about your game and how you got
checkmated on the kingside or how you
got checkmate it on the Queen side at
this moment you could say after Knight
takes pawn you lost upon to a discovered
double attack and I know exactly what
you were talking okay so here's a very
good time to take your move back
and I'll go with what the young man said
if you had played here I would have won
upon for free so how about Queen to a3
why could you capture now if you notice
what has happened in the game how many I
want to say units how many pieces and
pawns have high moved
how many pieces and pawns let us count
now how many of you moved okay so we say
in six so we say in chess that I'm a
head and development what does that mean
it means I've moved my more of my army
I've got more of my army into the game
than you have
I'm a head in development and I'm also a
head what is this called yes young man
what is it yes
correct but we call it force I'm ahead
in force or I'm ahead in material right
so a couple of things have already
happened from this opening I'm ahead in
force I'm ahead in development and I
have a very safe King so at this moment
I'm a big favorite I'm a big favorite to
win the game and what I'm going to do is
I'm going to continue to develop so now
I bring a bishop into play yes young man
Bishop g5 so because I brought a bishop
into play
you brought a bishop into play right
that was how you thought about okay
that's very logical right it's very
interesting what you just did you did it
subconsciously but it's what I do as
well I keep a running count do you do
many of you know who mr. Spock is oh he
was an actor yes do you know mr. Spock
well mr. Spock was a very very logical
person and he often counted time like
the captain of the ship would ask mr.
Spock what time it is and he'd give him
the exact time without looking at a
watch because he was making a
calculation of the time constantly
that's what I do I keep I constantly
count who's ahead in the force I
constantly count who's ahead in the
development and I also count who's ahead
in space shall we do that for a moment
without without answering right away how
many squares does white control think
about don't answer it right away and how
many squares does black control I'm
going to ask you in a moment
okay count how many squares you guys
control how many squares I control
are you ready no not yet
okay you're ready okay we got one person
ready who's ready to go you're ready
okay just a second okay so I'm going to
ask white controls two squares how many
believe it's to raise your head how
about three how about five
how about more than five raise your hand
if it's more than fight okay shall we do
it together this pawn how many this bond
zero you'd this bond doesn't attack any
of my space so we have to this night
that makes four right
the knight controls a five and g5 that's
4 so 2 4 and the bishop six
9 you guys control night
how many does black that's me the good
guy how many this is a good guy control
I control how many did you say more than
four more than four one one how many
squares is this night control of your
space how many does it control how many
does this pong control how about this
night so we're up to four how about this
Bishop three ah
that's a very good point the bishop is
on the g4 square that how many squares
does the bishop attack the bishop
attacks h3 and f3 but we don't say the
bishop attacks the square it's on okay
so this is very interesting so it
actually turns out that I control two
four six now I'm going to take your
night we're gonna play a couple of more
moves and then we'll stop I take your
night do you guys want to move your king
you want to move a rook how about your
queen
if you want to take my bishop that was a
good trade you guys did good for a
change
you trained how much is the night worth
now we've got a mathematician in their
class an accountant an economist okay
this is a very very fundamental thing
we're going to talk about now do you are
you aware of what means doubled pawns we
can see the double pawns the pawn on f3
in the pond our f2 are on the same file
so we say that white has doubled F pawns
very very clear and because you have
doubled F pawns do you see that your
queen your king pardon me it's a little
bit weakened okay so what I'm going to
do is I'm very happy that your queen is
over here but I don't like the fact that
my knight isn't doing so much so I'm
going to bring my knight back with the
idea of bringing it here and I want to
attack your double F pawn do you see how
I'm doing that mm-hmm and now what would
you what could you do I would love to go
right here attacking your queen but I'm
afraid I really take my knight oh you're
trying to trick me
turkey now that would be my move
but the young gentleman had a different
idea for me as well okay what he
suggested I might do is I might take
your pawn and then when you take my
knight we're there with a double pump
yeah that's very good because you wanted
to undone what would you suggest correct
with the bishop attacking your queen and
winning the rook except for one small
tiny detail what that did yes Queen will
take my bishop well that's a lousy idea
I would lose a bishop and a knight yeah
thank you very much indeed well I'm not
going to fall for that
ha ha ha ha not one chance I'm gonna
retreat my knight okay you guys are good
yes young man what would you do
okay Bishop takes f6 would you like to
make the trade it's a even trade even
Stephens it's three and three okay but
it's still haven't even trade okay the
gentlemen suggest okay let's just look
at this for a moment the bishop on g5
controls two squares correct f6 and h6
when your bishop takes my knight and i
recapture your bishop
how many squares does your bishop now
control it's gone it's gone there's no
more control correct but let's go back
for a moment in this moment how many
squares of yours does my bishop control
five think about it think about let me
repeat my question
No how many squares how many squares of
yours does this Bishop control it
doesn't well what square does it attack
why it's blocked by the knight but
that's my square it's not your square
this is my space this is your space show
me show me what vision okay just a
second this Bishop attacks this square
correct yes but that's my square it's
not your square this Bishop attacks f8
correct protective 8 so it doesn't
attack any of yours right now let's just
imagine that you take my night I
recapture with the bishop now hold on
hold on just a second you second a
second we made an even trade but how
many squares does your Bishop now
control now after the trade how many of
your squares does my Bishop now control
how many think it's to raise your hands
that's wrong how many think it's three
raise your hands how many think it's
this is tricky why is it four why is it
it attacks h4d four c3b two so it
attacks four squares so you really
helped me with this trade do you see
that now
that's true that is it a consideration
but you broke my fortress but you have
to weigh it about you have two chances a
little bit about negotiation right you
get me I get you but you also have to
think about the result the result we
should realize that as we calculate the
force the time the element of space that
that trait actually favors me because
you're getting rid of an active Bishop
and you're developing a passive bishop
on an active diagonal how many of you
would know the word passive passive
young man what do you think passive
means peaceful that's a nice word isn't
it so my bishop at the moment is a
peaceful Bishop and then it's going to
become an active bishop so wait so how
many of you would after this long
discussion how many of you would now
like to trade your Bishop for the knife
well we learned something so we're gonna
make a different move how many of you
would like to move your knight yes bring
your pieces out where would you like to
move your knight to d2 or to c3 young
lady
c3 okay now after Knight c3 I have a
really really really good move and I
want you guys to try to imagine what I
would like to play if I were black which
I have black so what's a really good
move what a move that you guys got to
worry about now young man
but if I move my night to g4 can't you
take my night but you win my night
that's not good for me ah but who
somebody came up with a real good move
just a moment ago not that night move
but another night move what's another
good
so this knight on c6 controls how many
squares d4 and b4
where could this Knight move it can only
move to the square it controls if it
goes to b4 is that a good move all right
so what's the other good square yes okay
correct Knight d4 now after I've moved
my knight to d4 what have I done
I made a fork correct I'm attacking two
pawns correct which pawns am i attacking
because if I capture this pawn my knight
will attack your Queen and rook correct
what's the other pawn that I'm attacking
though and if I take that pawn what will
my knight be forking in that case
correct I'm forking so in this position
this night is about to cause some very
serious damage you're going to lose
either this pond with a result that
you'll lose either the queen of rook or
you're going to lose this pawn which
will attack your king with check okay so
this point we're gonna stop and we're
gonna say you guys came really really
really close to almost winning a really
really really really close but what we
learned what we learned is what was I
trying to do against the class what was
I trying to do I was trying to develop
my army I was trying to control this
look what happened in the end by the way
I can draw and when that Knight landed
on the d4 square what what square is
that called sweet center so I developed
my Knight into the sweet center and it
came with devastating effect so what I
was trying to do was to develop my army
control the center King safety and I was
always conscious of how many spaces I
was winning and what the material was
and every chess game every Grandmaster
in the world does exactly what we did
just now